لم يتوقف الجدل في مصر حول فيلم الملكه
كليوباترا الذي اعلنت منصه نتفليكس انتاجه
وسيعرض اليوم الجدل طبعا يدور حول اظهار
المصريين القدماء من اصول افريقيه وهو ما
اغضب المصريين معتبرين تزييف لي الحقائق
من حركه الافرسان المركزيه الافريقيه طبعا
لم يقتصر الاعتراض على حملات الكترونيه
الى القضاء بدعاوى تطالب الدوله باتخاذ
الاجراءات القضائيه والدبلوماسيه ضد
المنصه وصنع الفيلم اضافه لدراسات
وتصريحات خرجت لكبار المؤرخين
والاثرين الذين طالبوا بتعويض مصر عن
تزيين في تاريخها القديم فيما اعلنت
الشركه المتحده للاعلام انتاج عمل وثائقي
عن الملكه كليوباترا امام كل هذه
الانتقادات قامت منصه نتفليكس بتعديد
تعديل تصنيف الفيلم من وثائقي فقط الى
وثائقي درامي لكي تضع لصانعيه مساحه حره
من استخدام الخيال دون الالتزام بالتاريخ
صوره واحده فقط صدرت من هنا في امريكا
وتحولت الى زلزال في مصر فما القصه
[موسيقى]
ببشره سمراء
ملصق دعائي لسلسله وثائقيه ستعرضها منصه
نتفليكس في العاشر من مايو السلسله تروي
سيره اخر ملكات مصر الفرعونيه ومنتجه
العمل ليست الا جيده
الذي دافع عنها خلال حفل الاوسكار في
العام الماضي
صفع حينها مقدم الحفل كروس روك بسبب نكته
سمجه عن شعر جيده لكن كيلوباترا السمراء
ويعني المفارقه تعيد جيد سميث الى الاضواء
وعنوان هذه المفارقه حركه
فكريه تعتقد ان مصر القديمه حكمها
الافارقه ذو البشره السمراء والفراعنه
قدموا من قلب افريقيا ليصبحوا فراعنه مصر
هذه الفكره تغضب المصريين كثيرا فكيف تبدو
صوره من ارض كيلوباترا صوره كليوباترا
السمراء تحولت ازمه وعرائضه مع عشرات الاف
الطواقيع والمطلب واحد اوقفوا عرض السلسله
ولكن هل هناك شيء من العنصريه في هذا
الغضب المصري
المعترضون لديهم رساله واضحه ليست هناك
مشكله ان تكون الملكه سمراء المشكله ان
يكون ذلك تزييفا للتاريخ
مرفوضون عموما هنا في مصر تذكروا
كليوباترا مصريه يونانيه وهي اخر من حكم
مصر القديمه
[موسيقى]
هذا الجدل دفعنا الى ام الدنيا في مصر
سالنا الناس ما رايك في موجه الغضب تجاهه
فيلم نتفليكس كليوباترا لبطله لبطله سمراء
اللون كانت في الفيلم ماذا
[موسيقى]
فيلم كليوباترا ان الكلام ده اصلا كله غلط
لان الناس كلها اتضايقت بسبب الموضوع ده
عشان المصريين اصلا مش اصلهم مش قليل من
الناس دي ولا
بطره المفروض احسن من كده بكتير يعني
كليوباترا بتحكي عن حضاره مصر
فالمفروض يعني كانت الصوره تبقى احسن من
كده يعني لان طبعا دي حضاره مصر وحضاره
البلد لازم
نهتم بها احسن من كده بكتير بيزيفوا
الحقايق يعني هم عاوزين يطلعوها مثلا
افريقيه او انها مش من اصول مصريه او انها
اي حاجه تاني
انما هم مش عاوزين يعترفوا بان مصر هي ام
الحضارات ومش عاوزين يعترفوا ان مصر هي
منبع لحضرات هو مش عنصريه كانت اللون بس
كان في الحمله اللي معموله اللي هو انتوا
بتاخدوا تاريخنا احنا بس ما هو اصلا كانوا
مصريين هو شايلوا كل المصريين حطوا
حطوا كل الناس اسمر اللون ما حطوش اي حاجه
تدور لان دول مصريين بس
معنا الان مشاهدينا من القاهره بسام
الشماع المؤرخ والمحاضر الدولي في علم
المصريات اذا اهلا بك استاذ بسام معنا في
صباح العربيه استاذ بسام دعنا ندخل في
الموضوع على طول نتفليكس غيرت تصنيف
الفيلم من
وثائقي الى وثائقي درامي
هل بذلك يعني رفعت
حرج هذا الجدل الكبير حول هذا الفيلم بما
انه يعني هناك مساحه عاده
للتصرف الدرامي في اي عمل فني
يعني في حقيقه الامر ان هذا نوع من انواع
التحايل في تغيير
توصيف الفيلم من فيلم دوكيمنتري او فيلم
وثائقي الى فيلم يعني دوكيو دراما ونلاحظ
هنا كلمه دوكيو في البدايه يعني كلمه
الوثائقي في البدايه كليوباترا ذات الاب
المجيد المحبه لامها كل هذه القابها
والدها معروف لدينا جميعا في التاريخ ولا
يوجد اي شك ولو واحد في الميه في اصله فهو
ابطال 12 او 12 كما يطلق عليه الان وهو
الملقب بيوليتس او الزمار لانه كانوا يحب
لعب الفلوت او الزماره وبالتالي هذا الرجل
هو مقدوني يوناني بامتياز 100% وهو ايضا
المسؤول عن دخول الرومان الى مصر هو كان
ملك ضعيف الحيه فعندما كان الرومان
مصادقين ال 12 وبداوا دخولهم وتحكمهم في
مصر وبعد وقفت امامهم كليوباترا السابعه
وهما الحياه الرومان فوجئوا بهذه الشخصيه
القويه فاذا نحن نعلم من هو ابوها
وبالتالي يجب ان نرجع الى الوان الجلد في
اليونان واليونان كانت تحوي الوان البني
والزيتوني للجلد وكان هناك ايضا الشكر
والبيض كونهم اوروبيين فيما بعد ولكن
الامر نحن لا نعلم من هي امها امها هي
المشكله يعني والده كليوباترا هي اللي
عليها علامه الاستفهام وربما هذا هو
المدخل الى ان ربما يكون والدتها سمراء
وهذا لم يذكر في هذا التاريخ هذا هذا ما
يدفعنا يعني السيد بسام الى انه اليوم
التاريخ الا يتحمل قراءه ثانيه من زاويه
اخرى لماذا هي هو ليس تابو بانه يكون
قراءه واحده وانتهى الموضوع
ولا لا
طبعا طبعا يتحمل نعم انا اوافق حضرتك على
انه يتحمل هذا الاختلاف واحنا في تاريخنا
وفي تاريخ العالم كله كثير جدا من علم
اسمه علم التنظير اي الثيورايزنج عايز انك
تضع هذه النظريات على مائده الحوار ولذلك
علاج هذه المعضله وعلاج هذه الافلام امثال
فيلم
كليوباترا وقيصر وفيلم كليوباترا تايلر
وفكره ايضا ان نعطي كليوباترا لون مش
لونها فهي لم تكن افريقيه والا كان ذكر
هذا المؤرخين امثال لترخص وبليني
وقتنا فقط طالما ذكرت بانه احنا ما بنعرف
من كانت والدتها فهناك احتمال انها كانت
سمراء وبالتالي يعني لا نستطيع ان نجزم
بانها كانت بيضاء اللون بشكل قاطع ولكن هل
ترى بانه كان هناك نوع من انواع العنصريه
في رد فعل المصريين
وموقفهم الرافد وبشده والجدل الليثار لانه
نتفليكس اظهرت كليوباترا ببشره سمراء
يجب ان ناخذ حذرنا في الرد على هذا النوع
من الطرح في ان احنا ما ننجرفش ناحيه
العنصريه او حتى ما اطلقت عليه انا
الشوفونيه الحضاريه وبالتالي انا ارى ان
حل هذه المشكله هو مؤتمر عالمي يتم في
القاهره وفي مدينه اسوان الجميله الرائعه
ويتم دعوه العفروسان من الولايات المتحده
الى هذا المؤتمر مع علمائنا الجمال انا
شخصيا حضرت في امريكا هم سهل اللي هم
تقنعيهم وبالتالي هذا المؤتمر يخرج
بتوصيات للعالم كله شكرا جزيلا لك الى
بسام الشماعه المؤرخ والمحاضر الدولي في
علم المصريات كان معنا من القاهره
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات